[Musique]
emmanuel macron à la rencontre des
habitants des quartiers nord de
marseille
ici beaucoup dénoncent un manque de
moyens criant depuis des années on est
oubliés des institutions moi j'espère
que vous allez mettre de l'argent sur
marseille pour nos écoles pour le lan je
n'avais rien dans la formation
bonjour en réponse emmanuel macron vient
avec un plan des de plusieurs milliards
qu'il détaillera demain mais il n'est
pas le premier depuis 10 ans à marseille
les annonces se succèdent marseille est
la deuxième île de france elle est donc
au plan national au tout premier rang de
nos préoccupations
cette ville a besoin du soutien très
déterminée de l'état pense pas que
marseille ait besoin de plus d'argent
parce que pour moi en fait de marseille
c'est comme l'afrique là à marseille ça
au gouffre financier qui chaque année
réclame de l'argent et ça ne gênait rien
de plus que ce qu'on voit c'est à dire
que dalle convoiterait par emmanuel
macron en 2022 et coûter jusqu'à preuve
du contraire oui si vous voulez
absolument que je m'engage pour le
moment jusqu'à preuve du contraire moi
je sais bien que quand il pleut c'est de
sa faute quand il fait froid c'est de sa
faute quand la voiture démarre pas c'est
de sa faute et quand il va à marseille
il fait du il fait un commercial bon
alors il n'y était pas d on aurait dit
quoi c'est toujours pareil je ne veux
pas égrainé des milliards parce que ça a
déjà été fait beaucoup de fois et
d'ailleurs on l'a dit c'est vrai vous
l'avez vécu ces milliards français pas
où ils vont parce qu'ils sont perdus
dans la division entre les collectivités
ont dit ces milliards cdte annoncé la
métropole le département la commune les
gens n'y comprennent plus rien il va
falloir en quelque sorte je le dis sans
naïveté inventé rêver marseille il est à
la fin de son mandat et que devant au
moins trois mois huit mois même pas un
an de son mandat c'est là qui vient se
rappeler qu'il ya une ville qui existent
en france qui s'appelle marseille et
qu'il faut soudainement reformé
réhabiliter reconstruit et injecter de
l'argent mais pour moi c'est un coup de
com' politique parce que là il à la fin
de son mandat logements et écoles
délabrées mais aussi un sécurité
ici un jeune de 21 ans a été tué en juin
dernier le trafic de drogue mille la vie
du quartier dans l'entraînement c'était
il ya des barricades les jeunes nous
demandent des pièces d'identité pour
rentrer dans nos immeubles c'est pas de
l'argent facile quand tu fais des nues
quand tu fais des poupées de 10 heures
quand tu fais de tp de 10h à minuit des
temps plein des temps plein mais quand
je fais de 10h à minuit et tu prends ta
paire minuit je te demande pas que tu
vas tu vendre le solde non merad l ademe
haddad m alors on va on va pas vous
plaindre adèle merci la soirée ya des
gens qui travaillent à l'usiné qui colle
avec deezer et qui gagne 1200 euros par
mois et travaille comme des chiens je
suis sûr vous gagnez pas 1200 euros par
mois des deux fois plus qu'est ce que
vous faites en un mois le travail et la
sécurité sociale depuis 20 ans
maintenant et vous histoire à part
perdre des dossiers non je perds rien à
vous les cherchez plus en plus on les
amène des dossiers d'accord
un truc là-bas on voit deux rivières un
peu voilà en fait les aztèques ici à
3500 je pense qu'ils paraissent sérieux
non par des plombs en fait c'est là
qu'on se parle
des trucs ludo-éducatif personnel
personnellement
politique les années une émission polis
parce que maintenant de toute façon il
faudrait absolument que l'éducation soit
forcément amusante
8 et 3 ha
ben non quelquefois c'est chiant et on
s'aperçoit dix ans plus tard ça a servi
à quelque chose l'été a été studieux et
fructueux pour benyamin ahmed ce
londonien de 12 ans a gagné plus de 340
mille euros grâce à ces weird wales ces
baleines étrange inspiré par l'univers
du jeu vidéo minecraft ces petites
images pixelisées avec chacune leurs
accessoires le jeune codeurs en a créé
plus de 3000 toutes sont mises aux
enchères en ligne comme des oeuvres
numériques les femmes nft dont le marché
explose ces derniers mois c'était notre
dernière le burning man est délocalisée
sur internet pandémie oblige alors les
fans pleurent cet événement hallucinant
qui a lieu depuis 35 ans aux états unis
en temps normal le burning man et bien
comme vous pouvez voir c'est un mélange
entre de l'art contemporain en plein air
et puis aussi une rave party dans tout
le désert du nevada ayumu d'où tu sors
comme ça mais de tokyo c'est au delà de
mes espérances
j'ai franchement je n'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un aussi kawai quel est ce que tu
peux retirer ta casquette que je vois
oh lalala lalala
ah oui
les organisateurs ont reproduit ils ont
reconstitué sur internet ce cette ville
donc les burner les plus motivés ils
peuvent enfiler un casque de réalité
virtuelle pour déambuler dans le décor
chacun a son petit avatar et il avance
un petit peu comme dans un jeu vidéo
donc les participants les plus agiles
peuvent se rendre à un concert c'est à
dire pour danser tout seul chez eux avec
casque de réalité fait il fallait rester
bien concentré ce jour là pour suivre le
bulletin météo lever les yeux du chien
du présentateur qui s'est invité en
plateau ou storm c'est son nom n'est pas
un inconnu des téléspectateurs en 2012
le voilà au beau milieu d'un facho
depuis l'animal est un peu devenu la
mascotte de cette chaîne de télévision
canadienne et quand il débarque à
l'antenne il a parfois le droit une
friandise nl et d'un recours à facebook
c'est pas sorti bon c'est pas rentrer
sur tout
[Applaudissements]
ensuite qui me place ces crèmes dans un
moule le cep a jamais fait avec ça donc
là on est complètement dans les normands
le plus total alors nous à paris on dit
innovation team mais bon nous ne sommes
pas là pour parfaire votre vocabulaire
selon les chercheurs de l'université de
kiel en allemagne le port de la cravate
réduire l afflux sanguin vers le cerveau
rétrécissement des artères carotides qui
sur la durée pour avoir des conséquences
des maux de tête des étourdissements des
maux ces chiffres est temps de voir
venir boire plus grave une augmentation
de la pression oculaire mais des risques
par ailleurs man u a des lunettes c'est
pas un hasard
il vous fait l'aja par ben oui oui à bas
les enfants manon n'a pas le même
cabinet de toilette
ont fait pas fait pas pipi pop aux mêmes
droits on partage pas non mais jamais
mes pattes mais comment j'entendais pas
tomber bien sûr que si on s'impose pas à
une préparation avant l'entrée en scène
des phrases un proverbe qui dit c'est
pas quand on a fait caca dans sa culotte
qu'il faut serrer les fesses c'est trop
tard